[Musique]
le musée des beaux-arts de l'ontario se
couvre de bleu à l'occasion d'une
exposition unique en son genre picasso
penning du groupe iliad est la première
exposition au canada à se concentrer
uniquement sur le début de carrière de
pablo picasso est entre 1901 et 1904 ses
oeuvres monochrome offre un nouvel
éclairage sur l'état d'esprit du grand
maître espagnol et permettent d'entrer
dans la tête deux jeunes picasso
plusieurs oublient que picasso n'avait
que 20 ans quand la période bleue a
débuté rappelle le commissaire
d'exposition
parmi les thèmes récurrents de la
période bleue on retrouve la pauvreté la
misère et la charité avec une
inspiration marquée de l'art religieux
mais l'exposition présentée par la géo
ne se distingue pas uniquement par les
thèmes qui sont présentés mais aussi par
la méthodologie entreprises par le musée
car en plus de recueillir 94e oeuvres
signées par picasso la géo a soumis
trois de ses tableaux à une examinations
par evrard rouge qui a permis de
découvrir les brouillons souci peinture
marquantes
de voir qu'ils ont trouvé une peinture
sous la peinture c'est fascinant lançait
torontoise
ce travail minutieux on a pris sept ans
et l'exposition est presque tombé à
l'eau en raison de la pandémie et des
nombreux contrats de prêts qu'il a fallu
renégocier
c'est toute une chance on risque de ne
plus pouvoir revoir ses tableaux
souligne cette femme de picasso
l'exposition sera présentée à la géo
jusqu'au 16 janvier après toronto ce
sera au tour du musée phillips
collection de washington d'accueillir la
collection et de lui aussi se couvrir de
bleu et si le métier radio canada
toronto